I want to start with congrats on the
sequel I really sincerely hope it's a
huge hit for you guys
um I because I don't want to spoil
anything in the movie I am curious if
you were able to leave set
um and like steal one of the costumes
and go somewhere wearing you know what I
mean yeah where would you like to go and
why in my costume like no no like if you
could steal one of the Shazam outfits
okay I would steal Lucy Liu's outfit and
I would walk around uh Five Little Five
Points in Atlanta and blend just right
in nobody would notice nobody would like
spot anything strange I'd say Zach and I
super soon probably go to the mall with
it oh my God you probably fly around
though that'd be pretty meta you know
walk into like some kind of designer
store right yeah they think of it I
think you're eccentric maybe they just
give it to me for free because I can fly
yeah it'll be fun just like float in
there exactly just Glide in there hey
it's like a Rolex place you know yeah
can I get a Rolex that's on the house
thank you okay oh one of the things that
I think David does so well in both films
is that he's able to balance like the
humor but also has some pretty dark
stuff in it like and I don't want to be
specific in the sequel but there was a
scene I was like oh is that really oh it
is gonna happen
um it involves um a roof I'll say it
like that
um and so yeah yeah like that's not the
norm and I'm just curious if you talk a
little bit about that about how he's
able to thread that line
well I love that question actually
because I've always said about David
that coming from a horror background I
think horror and comedy are probably the
most similar of genres like comedy and
drama you could combine the two but I
think horror and comedy because you're
both trying to you're trying to evoke an
emotion a strong singular specific
emotion whether it's fearful or comedy
but also when you're laughing at
something when something is it's because
it's it's because it's it's shocking
it's affecting it's it it jars you you
know it's so I think he's found a really
great
um dynamic between uh
the realism and and and and affecting
the audience and moving them uh with
comedy and also with Darkness it's very
natural to comes to him anything you
want to add I think that was great I
think yeah thank you I think he's really
good at balancing the two and you're
really good at uh yeah really just
telling the story
um but yeah there's nothing else really
to add that's great one of the things I
heard about Zach is that he likes to
play music
um on set and I've been on sets before
that is unusual where someone but I mean
uh he is unusual yeah that is also true
yeah and I was gonna say though that
what is it like actually working with
someone who sort of sets that tone and
what does that music sort of do on set
it's such a uh welcoming environment
like anytime Zach's around it's just
like it's just you're comfortable and he
makes you he makes you comfortable and
it's just a feel-good vibrant
um Vibe on the set and he's just so fun
to be around and
um we just have the the best time
together
um so I think you know having that
because I guess you really
you never know the type of set you're
gonna show up to so you know the fact
that we have this amazing cast
I don't know warmth I bring in humility
I bring incense to creative he brings
annoyance annoyance I'm just kidding and
incense yeah yeah not Champa actually
that's mine but no it's such a great
environment and I think you know a part
of the reason why it's like that is
because of him he brings that what do
you think fans of Shazam would be
surprised to learn about the making of
the sequel I can't make jokes because I
get in trouble every time so I'm gonna
say that
um I don't I don't have it I don't have
a serious answer I mean there was a love
triangle between me and Lucy Lou and
Helen Mirren
there it is that's a joke by the way but
that's all I can think about that's why
you can't tell jokes I can't but
whatever my PR is laughing so I think
I'm in the I mean I was gonna say but it
was edited out like that that part of
the story they're all live well now it's
in the real world no no I'm saying like
that part of the movie was edited out
yeah yes no it totally was filmed yeah
it was I let somebody film it but I
don't know if David was involved in that
I don't know exactly
um
huge hit